When Athena talks about the possible area's of the fun room to other people at
the architecture firm, she's probably not going to want to talk about any values
of x that aren't allowed. She'll really only want to focus on the ones that are
in the domain. In the set of allowed possible values for x or inputs. As we said
earlier, the domain of this function is x is greater than 0, because of the
restrictions placed upon it by the real life situation it's representing. As
we've learned throughout the class, one of the best ways to visualize most
things in math is through graphing, and domain is no exception. Looking at what
I have plotted here, we can see that the only points on our graph have x
coordinates that lie within this domain. It's a little bit hard to see here, but
rather than having a filled in circle at the point 0,0 there's actually a tiny
little open circle, just like we saw in number lines before. The fact that
there's an open circle at this end point is just showing that this end point is
not included in the domain. If instead we've had x is greater than or equal to
0, this would be a filled in circle, but we don't. And of course we could also
write our domain in interval notation. X lies in the range 0 to infinity not
including either end point.